what is the best tablet in the world is
it apple with their m1 ipad pro or is it
samsung with their brand new galaxy tab
s8 ultra well today we will find out
once and for all in this detailed
comparison where we're going to compare
the displays the speakers the
performance of the cpu and graphics and
more let's go ahead and get this unboxed
and just like before
we do not have a charger in the box you
just get the tablet whereas apple they
even though they started this trend they
still give you one now holding this in
my hands i gotta say it feels very thin
the crazy thing is that even though this
is the largest tab it is also the
thinnest which feels kind of weird but
nice in your hand but it is really nice
that they include an s pen in the box so
you don't have to go and spend another
130 bucks like you do with the apple
pencil we'll compare the performance of
these in just a sec now taking a look at
the tablets themselves even though the
ipad pro is large
this thing is a lot bigger look how tall
this is when they're in a vertical
orientation it is
massive let me stack this up
right there side by side you guys can
see
all that extra space now if we go ahead
and put the ipad on top of the ultra it
is just slightly wider meaning that even
though this samsung tab s8 ultra is 14.6
inches
in reality it is mostly because of its
aspect ratio being way wider so it's
actually narrower now that could be good
for watching videos and movies things
like that we'll see how good it does as
far as the ole display compared to mini
led now as far as cameras this camera
bump is quite small
it's kind of a long shape like they've
been using for a while and it does not
have the lidar sensor that apples does
it just includes two lenses and a flash
and we'll take some photos in a sec and
taking a look at the front yes the
samsung tablet now features a notch and
that's because they have two cameras
there which we will test out but i just
want to show you guys just how this
screen looks compared to the ipad it
just makes the large ipad look small
when it's right next to it the tab does
have an under display fingerprint
scanner it works pretty well seems
almost like it's faster than the s8 plus
but maybe it's just i don't know working
better now i do prefer face id because
it is automatic you swipe up you're
logged in or if you have the magic
keyboard you just press the space bar
and it'll clear it and if you're opening
up an app it will automatically just log
you in without having to use your
fingerprint both these tablets have quad
speakers and i'm excited to hear how
good the speakers are in this ultra
sized tablet from samsung so let's go
ahead and compare them
[Music]
all right guys you heard that for
yourselves go ahead and let me know down
below what your thoughts are to me it's
evident that the ipad pro sounds better
it is louder and has deeper bass it's
interesting to hear some tech reviewers
say these speakers are so good in here
they beat out the ipad we have a really
nice thousand dollar recording set up
here and you guys heard that so uh
definitely the ipad for the win there
but the samsung still gets pretty loud
it sounds good especially for being that
thin now as far as microphone quality
this is the video from the ipad pro
using the wider mode to record and this
is kind of the quality that you can
expect of course so you can enable the
center stage feature for conferences
online but one thing that i don't like
about the ipad is that the camera is
over here so it's set up for a vertical
orientation but then when you are using
a keyboard case like a lot of people do
when they are recording or conferencing
um then your camera is off to the side
and so when you're looking at the person
that you're talking to it looks like
you're avoiding them on camera and this
is the microphone and video quality of
the tab s8 ultra now i gotta say
this 4k footage looks really crispy the
ipad only does 1080p because it has a
single ultrawide camera that just crops
in where this has dual camera so you can
switch from that close-up shot to a wide
angle without having to use digital crop
which ruins your quality and it allows
for 4k
recording now you guys let me know do
you like the setup better um i do wish
there was no notch there for that like
the ipad doesn't have a notch but i
think it is quite cool to have this
ability so go ahead and let me know
which one looked better and which one
sounded better down in the comment
section now as far as the cameras here
are photos using the front facing selfie
cameras go ahead and let me know if you
can really tell if that digital crop on
the ipad makes a big difference and
here's some comparison shots from the
regular 1x camera as well as the ultra
wide personally to me i'm not very
impressed with those rear camera modules
but the selfie cameras do look quite
good especially that one that's more
close up but that is actually not a
horrible thing because you don't really
use those back cameras that often or at
least you probably shouldn't because
most smartphones look better than that
but the front cameras you do use more
often and now let's go ahead and get
into the displays both these are high
resolution 120 hertz displays but the
samsung only allows you to either choose
120 hertz or if you want standard 60hz
to get better battery life whereas apple
allows you to use pro motion which is
constantly variable keeps everything
smooth and saves battery at the same
time now samsung is using an ammo led
display compared to apple using mini led
and that can make a pretty significant
difference
first off as far as maximum brightness
let's go ahead and crank that all the
way up i'll go ahead and adjust that top
camera so it doesn't blow out the
brightness looks really close just
sitting here maxing these out but where
the ipad really comes in is when you're
watching hdr content because it can
reach up to a thousand six hundred nits
that really makes hdr video look amazing
because you can have super bright
highlights that really pop in video the
samsung looks pretty good and the fact
that it's oled allows the pixels to
completely shut off
to give you perfect blacks and that
definitely helps in darker environments
but unfortunately the glass that samsung
is using is very reflective and that
gives the ipad actually deeper blacks
because it has way better
anti-reflectivity coatings but the issue
with the ipad is that sometimes you can
see blooming especially if you're in
lower light and especially in completely
black rooms with the display brightness
maxed out and when you have menu items
that are white on dark you can see that
now some of you guys asked for sdr video
because not everybody watches hdr and
looking at him they are a lot more
similar
now the ipad is still a little bit
brighter because the display in general
can hit 600 nits compared to samsung
advertisers 400 and looking at the
blacks right here the blacks look a lot
deeper and darker on the ipad once again
because of reflectivity now i do have to
say that it does seem like the ultra has
a nicer display than just the tab s8
plus the specs look very similar but it
does look brighter at least more
competitive to the ipad and i also
really like the wider aspect ratio you
guys see there's the black bars here are
very minimal we get a larger image
compared to the ipad but overall
including the speaker quality and the
high brightness i would say like that
the ipad does have a nicer display now
for those of you guys who take notes and
draw how do the pens compare well i will
say that i do think the apple pencil is
nicer it is heavier feels a lot more
quality but you got to buy it for 130
bucks compared to getting this for free
in the box which is amazing the
performance of the apple pencil has
always been really really good since we
got pro motion you can't really notice
any lag or delays in a previous video we
showed off some slow motion footage how
the s pen really lagged now some of you
guys commented and said that we need to
go into the notes app manually to
actually get the full performance of
this s pen that has been updated to have
even less latency than apple pencil so
here you go i went in here
super super smooth no delay whatsoever
so sensitivity is good um i really have
no complaints samsung did an excellent
job but they included this in the box i
guess my only complaint is that this
performance is not system wide like it
is with the ipad and now let's get into
performance the first thing that i want
to test is the speed of the storage with
these devices both are 250 gigabyte
models or so so let's go ahead and start
our test the ipad's already done with
2782
read and
2245 right incredible performance and
that is needed because uh this ipad has
a thunderbolt port so if you're gonna be
transferring files you want the
performance so apple did spend the money
to get really fast storage and here you
go for the samsung we have a thousand
three hundred read and 630
right that's over two times faster as
far as read and three and a half times
faster in terms of right so you're
definitely getting your money's worth
with the ipad compared to the samsung
which is a lot slower and then of course
you just have that usb type-c port which
means that you can't hook up to a hub or
an adapter that gives you a lot more
ports you'll have much slower transfer
speeds and things like that now what
about the processor performance we have
the latest snapdragon 8 gen 1 processor
compared to the legendary m1 and here in
geekbench 5 well we have a significant
difference the ipads single core
performance is double what the latest
snapdragon offers in this tablet and the
multi-core performance is about 2.2
times
so that is a huge huge difference in
performance i feel like qualcomm really
needs a process designed for the desktop
that has more power
and yes this is a thin device but the
ipad is pretty much the same thickness
maybe ever so slightly thicker and it's
getting this performance now wondering
if you test that we did it last time
with the tab s8 plus so i have
geekbench's machine learning benchmark
here it's going to test out what these
can do as far as machine learning and
you guys know a lot of that is now being
used for image processing audio there's
a bunch of stuff so let's go ahead and
run this benchmark all right and we have
a result and it's a pretty big
difference we have 1017 here and 457
for the tab s8 ultra now as far as
graphics last time we ran 3d marks
wildlife this time i'm going to use gfx
bench and we're going to run the very
popular aztec ruins the off screen test
that way there's no difference in
resolution that could affect it and bam
we have our results and the m1 ipad
scored 82.2 frames per second compared
to
38.
now of course this is one test and there
are differences in the real world we
have thermal differences so vadim is
going to be doing a gaming test where he
actually has it connected to another
computer that is monitoring the frame
rates and it will be able to show you
guys that real time so if you guys want
to see that make sure you guys are
subscribed so we definitely know that
the ipad is the more powerful tablet by
far
with the m1 processor with the
thunderbolt port with that fast storage
so what does the samsung do well or what
are the standout features well we have
an sd card slot where you can put in
your own storage of course it's not
going to be even as fast as internal
storage here but that can save you a lot
of money instead of having to buy it
built in
and charging a lot like apple does with
their ipad now along with that you have
decks now unfortunately i don't have the
keyboard for this to set it up like i
did last time but here's some footage
from
the tab s8 plus and dex gives you so
much flexibility to be able to use it as
a desktop operating system you can
connect it to a display there are no
limitations with android and with decks
whereas with the ipad like i talked
about in my full review apple is really
locking down ipad os there are so many
little things that you can't do and that
don't work for example external monitor
support
that you could just connect your stuff
is cut off and it doesn't make sense
because on the ipad you can change uh
change your
split view and everything adjust
properly so apple just does not want
this to be a laptop replacement where
with the tab it pretty much is even
though it doesn't have the performance
now unfortunately because this is a new
size those keyboards were sold out
quickly and that was a bummer
considering that samsung is charging 350
dollars
for that keyboard case which is insane i
complained about it with apple's magic
keyboard case but at least with this
even though i still think it's
overpriced you have this nice hinge it
floats and the trackpad is excellent
it's not a diving board design and then
you get the extra port to be able to
charge up while you're using your
thunderbolt port and samsung's keyboard
is not as nice but they're selling it
also for 350 bucks and people are buying
it but with all of that said
which one of these tablets is the best
tablet in the world and honestly once
we've seen the performance we saw how
the screen compares i think that even
android fanboys have to admit that the
ipad with the m1
is the king of all tablets not only do
you have that 1600 nits display you also
have the better speakers we have
the cameras that are better on the back
with lidar you also have incredible
performance the storage
it is a nice nice machine it's just a
shame that apple limits ipad os so much
it has so much potential
but they still want you to buy a macbook
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below check out
one of those great videos right over
there this one max and i'll see you in
the next video